ضعت الامم المتحده طرفي الصراع في السودان
الى التفاوض لانهاء الحرب باسرع وقت ممكن
وحذرت من استمرار الصراع لم يؤدي الا
لتدمير البلاد
ممكن ذاك الخبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما اسباب تصاعد وتيره
المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع مؤخرا
ما هي التاثيرات الداخليه والدوليه
المحتمله للتصعيد الراهن بل مسارات
المحتمله للوضع في السودان على ضوء
الاوراق التي يراهن عليها كل من طرفي
الصراع
[موسيقى]
هناك قلق من ان العنف يتزايد
وان الجهود للتوصل الى
التراجعت
وبالرغم من محاوله دفع الطرفين المتصارعين
لكي يعود السودان الى وضع يختار فيه الشعب
حكامه وذلك ما نامل اليه ولكنني اشعر بقلق
شديد حول مسار العنف حاليا في السودان
هنالك عده عوامل اسهمت بشكل مباشر في
تصاعد حده المواجهات العسكريه مؤخرا بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع اهم
انا في تقديري الاستراتيجيه التي كانت
تتبع القوات المسلحه المرتبطه ارتباط وثيق
باستراتيجيه الدفاع عن المقرات الاجهزه
العسكريه والامنيه والى حد ما مقار اجهزه
الدوله الان تغيرت بعد ثلاث اشهر من
المواجهات العسكريه وربما كانت الاخوات
المسلحه تعتمد على سياسه النفس الطويل او
سياسه الاستنزاف انهاك العدو وعندما ادركت
بان حان الوقت للتحرك باستخدام قدر اكبر
من القوه ربما هذه هي مؤشرات القوه
المميته بانهم يستخدموا قدر عالي جدا من
القوى الامر الذي اثر على شكل كبير جدا
على حياه المدنيين في بعض الاحيان الجزئيه
الاخرى وهي المهمه بحيث ان طرفين الصراع
ما زالوا يفضلون الخيار العسكري لحسم
مجريات المعرفه في ظل تراجع فرص الحلول
الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه
ان الجهد الامريكي
يتماشى مع قلته نحتاج اولا وقفا لاطلاق
النار وان يكون هناك دعم انساني للمحتاجين
المشكل بالنسبه لوقت النار لدينا
طرفان متصارعان لا احد منهما يسيطر على
الاخر وذلك يزيد من دوامه العنف اذا دعم
بلدان هذا الطرف او ذاك الامر يصعب التوصل
الى حل بشانه ينبغي ان يتوقف مد اي من
الطرفين بالاسلحه حتى يعود الى المفاوضات
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده والسعوديه سوف
يركزان على ذلك
وسيتطلب من ذلك من الجانبين ان يوافق على
ذلك لكن ينبغي ان يكون هناك ضغوط اضافيه
من قبل طرفين ومن قبل الدول الاخرى حتى
يتم التوصل الى مثل هذا الحل
انسحاب قوات الدعم السريع من الاحياء
وكذلك المنشات الصحيه والمدنيه والخدميه
هذه نقطه ظلت خلافيه الوساطه للاسف الشديد
لم تتمكن من ايجاد حلها لا سيما يتعلق
بخروج الدعم السريع من الاحياء ربما رؤيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي دائما ما
تعتقد بان لا تعمل السريع هي مليكه لديها
سجل من الانتهاكات والفظائع وفي الجانب
الاخر تتهم الجيش السوداني بانه مؤلف لذا
هي لم تطرح قضيه فعليه متمثله في انسحاب
الدعم السريع وكذلك ممارسه الضغوط على
القوات المسلحه حتى يتثنى للطرفين للتواصل
الى موقع او موقف تفاضي
موضوعي او محل تقدير لدى الطرفين من بعد
الوصول الى تفاهمات
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده
لن ترسل بطبيعه الحال اي قوه حفظ سلام حتى
يكون هناك اتفاق ووقف وانطلاق النار يمكن
ان يسلط عقوبات واذا كانت كان احد الاطراف
يرفض العقوبات فلن تطبق المجتمع الدولي
لاسيوم الدول التي تمتلك حق النقد الفيتو
في مجلس الامن الدولي بينها تقاطع كبير
للمصالح لا سيما في اطار عنا افريقيا الان
اصبحت الساحه
الامم المتحده وكذلك مجلس الامن الدولي
مشغول بقضاء اخرى قضايا ذات تعقيدات
وتاثيرات اكبر ربما من القضيه السودانيه
وتداعياتها على امن الاستقرار القاره
الافريقيه هو منطقه القرن الافريقي بالاخص
[موسيقى]
المعطيات المتوفره على ميزان القوات تميل
لصالح الجيش بشكل واضح لكن طبيعه المعركه
المتواجده دائما اوصات المدنيين وكذلك
المنشات يجعل من الصعب جدا انه الجيش يحقق
انتصارات السريعه الازمه في السودان هي
واضحه المعالم ومعلوم تماما ان القوات
الدعم السريع هي يتوفر لها دعم خارجي
وغطاء خارجي متمثل في دوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده هنا في تقدير الله الجانب
السوداني والحكومه السودانيه ممثله في
الجيش او في وزاره الخارجيه لم تقل ذلك
صراحه
اعتقد ان توقعات هي انها ستكون هناك
استمرار
للمعارك لانه لا احد من الطرفين يمكنه ان
يحسم الامر وذلك سيلحق ضررا كبيرا بالشعب
السوداني ويجعل من الصعب وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه